TO THE HAS LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
HEARING OR CRYING MUST BE
WARNED IF YOU DON'T HAVE A MASK
FOR THEM FOR YOU. AND WE HAVE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR TESTIMONY
HERE IN THE ROOM. AS WELL AS
REMOTE TESTIMONY AS WELL AS
THAILAND AND- FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT IS NAME ORGANIZATIONS
THIS ON THE BILL. CALLING
NUMBER FOR THE HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO NINE
FIVE SEVEN ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN- N. ALL RIGHT SO I'LL ASK
OUR MEN STRUCTURE IF YOU CAN
TAKE WILL PLEASE. KALRA HERE
FLORA GONZALEZ HERE JONES
SAWYER THEY'RE RARE. ADULT HERE
ONE. GREAT ESTABLISHED WE HAVE
QUORUM AND WE HAVE A ONE SING
BILL SANDRA HERTZBERG SIX SIX
OR YOU MAY BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND HIS TEAM MEMBERS.
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING
TO SOLVE WHY WE SEEKING TO
AMEND THE LAW IN CALIFORNIA IS
THERE LEGITIMATE PURPOSE. AND
THE JUDGMENT PURPOSE HERE IS
THAT WE HAVE A HISTORY WITH THE
JANITORIAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF A JANITORIAL BUSINESS ON
MAKE IT SHORT. HE THE GENTLE
BUSINESS WHICH IS UNIQUE
BECAUSE THERE'S EXTRAORDINARILY
DOWNWARD PRESSURE FOR
COMPETITION IN CONTRACT OUT
JANITORIAL SERVICES YOU KNOW
MATTER OF FACT IS THAT THE
REPORT HERE CALLED RACE TO THE
BOTTOM REALLY A MAKES THE POINT
OF BY BERKELEY SOME OF IT BACK
IN THE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
WITH RESPECT TO THE NUMBERS
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY FOLKS IN
THIS BUSINESS AND SO THE
QUESTION IS CAN WE LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD- RESPONSIBLE
CONTRACTORS WHAT CAN WE DO
THAT'S CREATIVE IN THE LAW. TO
INCENTIVIZE BEHAVIOR THAT
AVOIDS THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE TO PUT THIS DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON THESE FOLKS THAT
ARE ALWAYS PUSHED TO THE
BOTTOM. THIS UNBELIEVABLE
COMPETITION AND SO THIS MEASURE.
WHICH DEALS WITH OUR- EXEMPTING
JANITORIAL SERVICES NEARLY
CRAFTED UP FROM PAGA IF THE
EMPLOYEES WORK IS COVERED BY A
VALID COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT THAT COVERS THIS
ISSUE. WE THINK IT'S A CREATIVE
APPROACH IN THAT REGARD AND SO
I WILL CUT IT SHORT SINCE THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND I WILL
TURN IT OVER TO MY VERY STEAMED
WITH THIS. MISTER MEMBERS
DHINGRA FIFTEEN OR FEEL ON
BEHALF OF ABM INDUSTRIES
INCORPORATED. AND SPONSORED FOR
SB SIX FOUR SIX. JOINING ME IS
CHRISTINE VA SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT. AND DEPUTY GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR AB AND CANCER MORE
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR OFFERING
THIS MEASURE. CHAIR KALRA AND
COMMITTEE STAFF APPRECIATE TIME
YOU SPENT. SPEAKING WITH ON
THIS WORK. SPEAKING WITH ON
THIS BILL IN THE WORK PUT INTO
IT. I DO NOT HAVE MUCH MORE TO
SAY TO ADD AND WHAT SENATOR PER
HAS ALREADY SHARED.
FUNDAMENTALLY SB SIX FOUR SIX
WILL HELP PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY. WHAT WAS MUTUALLY
AGREED UPON THE A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. FOR DECADES WE
BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS TIME AND TIME
AGAIN RECOGNIZES SUPPORTED THE
SANCTITY OF COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING FOR UNIONS AND
EMPLOYERS. SIMILAR TO AB
SIXTEEN POINT FIFTY FOUR IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW. BUT IN AN EVEN MORE
NARROW WAY SB SIX FOUR SIX
ALLOW THE CBA TO BE FULLY
REALIZED. THE BILL WILL ONLY
IMPACT APPROXIMATELY 11% OF
JANITORS IN CALIFORNIA. TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND EMPLOYEES WHO
WERE POOR PREDOMINATELY LATINO
IMMIGRANTS FLY BY NIGHT
JANITORIAL CONTRACTORS TO OFTEN
MAKE A FAST BUCK. OFF THE BACKS
OF THESE LATINOS THREATENING
THE STABLE AND STRONG WAGES AND
BENEFITS WE PROVIDE AS WE
CONTINUE TO STRIVE TO BE A GOOD
CORPORATE CITIZEN. BY VOTING IN
FAVOR OF SB SIX FOUR SIX YOUR
RIVAL WILL HELP ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS OF SCOFFLAW
SUBCONTRACTORS THAT USE OTHER
SCOFFLAWS. THAT SKIRT THE LAW
AS ARTICULATED IN UC BERKELEY'S
REPORT. YOUR VOTE WILL HELP
STRENGTHEN OUR CBA'S. AND
STRENGTHEN OUR CBA'S AND
DECADES LONG RELATIONSHIPS
WE'VE HAD WITH ASCII. PLEASE
VOTE AYE ON THIS PIECE SIX FOUR
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND. WE ALSO HAVE A YOU'RE
GONNA. A ROOM ON THE- IT AFTER.
HELLO CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS
JACKIE THE AND THAT THE OF THE
MAKING OF BARBARA TRUCK FUND
ALSO KNOWN AS IMPEDIR. THIRTY
TRAVELS ESTABLISH IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE OF THE TAP PARTLY
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN S. YEAH YOU
YOU WOULD W. AND RESPONSIBLE
JANITORIAL CONTRACTORS AND.
PROPERTY SERVICES INDUSTRY. AND
WE'RE STATEWIDE Y. GROUP THAT
WORKS TO ELIMINATE ILLEGAL AND
BEEN FOR IN CALIFORNIA.
INDUSTRY THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY
THE NTS HAS FOUGHT TO COMBAT
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY. LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD AND PROTECT
WORKERS. YEAH WE HAVE CREATED.
WILL GRADING BECAUSE THE UNION
LAW ABIDING CONTRACTORS REALIZE
THAT THEY NEED TO DO MORE TO
PROTECT. THE RIGHT TO A FAIR
MARKET PLACE. IF I WORK ON THE
NON SECTOR OF OUR INDUSTRY WILL
OFTEN FIND YOUR RESPONSE CONTRA
WILL. WE GET OUR LAWS.
CREATING- SITUATION OF
INSURANCE IN THE WORKPLACE LAWS
ARE BEING VIOLATED BOTH ON THE
PUBLIC HEALTH SITE WE NEED TO
GET CALLOSUM BALL ALSO ON THE
PERSONAL SIXTY FIVE. BOB EVERY
GARCIA SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN THE
WORKPLACE. WE INVESTIGATE WICKS
DEATH IN OUR INDUSTRY AND WE
WERE EXPERIENCE WE CAN
VALIDATE. THE STUDIES WHICH
INDICATE THE WAIT STAFF IS FAR
MORE RAPID AND THE NONUNION
JANITORIAL SERVICES FOR TYPICAL
FIFTY LAYERS OF SUBCONTRACTORS
WHO USE THIS ARRANGEMENT TO
CONCEAL WICKS. THAT'S PART OF
OUR WORK WE PROVIDE ALSO SEXUAL
VIOLENCE AND HARASSMENT
PREVENTION TRAINING TO NONUNION
JANITORS SO THAT THEY KNOW THE
RIGHT ON THE JOB THEY FELT. AND
WAGE THEFT AND CRIME IN OUR
INDUSTRY BUT WE MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE AWARE OF THEIR MINIMUM
WAGE MAILING ADDRESS BREAK OVER
TIME- AND THEIR WORKPLACE AND
THE RIGHT TO HAVE A WORKPLACE
FREE OF HARASSMENT. MORE WE
INVESTIGATE WHICH ARE INJURED
WITH. TAKE THE TO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER SO THAT YOU CAN
CONDUCT OF THAT. SHOULD THE
GIRL SILVA FORTUNATE BOTH THE
WE ALSO WORK WITH VERY SECURE
ATTORNEY. TO BRING TO AGAINST
OR COMPANY. AND WE ALSO WORK
WITH WORKERS THE POWER CAN TO
BE COMP. FOR CLAIMS IN FACT
HARASSMENT CLAIM. ALSO PUT
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE TO OSHA.
TO CONTINUE OUR. IN SUPPORT. OF
SB SIX TWENTY SIX TO STATE YOUR
NAME. AND ORGANIZATION
IDENTIFICATION AND A POSITION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN NAY
BAYARDO WITH THIS YEAR YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
AMERICA YOSHI ARE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PLANET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION ALSO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA WERE IN
BETWEEN I'M JUST APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH OTHERS OFFICE IN
THE SPONSORS AND SEIU. WE
RECOGNIZE THE GENERAL INDUSTRY
IS UNIQUE THESE ARE WORKERS
REPRESENTED BY A UNION- WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
TERMS ARE VERY CLEARLY DEFINED
THAT IF THERE IS A PAGA
SUBSTITUTE THAT IT IS STRONG-
IF THESE WORKERS ARE WAVING
THEIR PAGA RIGHT. I'M SO
HOPEFUL HOPING TO WORK OUT
THOSE AMENDMENTS AND JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE BUT WANT TO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM. FOR IF NOT ANYONE IN
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
SUNDAY. AND THEN ANYONE ON THE
PHONE- IN SUPPORT OF SB. SIX
FORTY SIX. YOU'RE ON THE PHONE
MODERATOR. ELEMENT TO COMMENTED
SUPPORT SB SIX FORTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOU A LINE NUMBER MUST
APPEAR LINE NUMBER TO BE CALLED
FOR YOUR COMMENT ONCE AGAIN
PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE. ONCE
AGAIN BURKE DOES SUPPORT PLUS
ONE ZERO. WHAT I MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO COMMENTERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY LISTED
OPPOSITION WITNESSES OR ANYONE
IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION. IF
NOT REMOTE TESTIMONY AND THEN A
MODERATOR IS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION SB SIX FOUR
SIX. THAT'S A COMMENT OVER THE
PHONE OPPOSITION SIX FOUR SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. I WANT
TO MISTER CALDERON- COMMENTERS
IN OPPOSITION I THINK YOU WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
YOU DO HAVE A MOTION RIGHT NOW
ON THE TABLE ANY COMMENT YES.
IT WAS A PLEASURE. IF THERE'S A
SECOND ONE OF THOSE AREN'T EVEN
ON MOTION THANK YOU SO MUCH. A
LOT OF SET MOTIONS AND SECONDS
GOING ON AND SO- WITH THAT- YOU
KNOW APPRECIATED I KNOW THAT IN
TERMS OF SOME OF THE DETAILS
THINGS DO SURELY MORE PROPER
DISCUSSION ON SOME OF THE
TERMINOLOGY. OF LEGAL
TERMINOLOGY AND I THINK BUT
ALMOST HALF OF COMMITTEES ON
THAT COMMITTEE AS WELL AS WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO- THE TO
TAKE A CLOSER LOOK SO WITH
THAT- CENTER WAS LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS CHAIR
MEMBERS JUST- STRESSING UNIQUE
NATURE OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT'S RELIABLE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOT A
SEXUAL CAN YOU. ROLL ON ISSUE
SIX FORTY SIX PLEASE. MORE IS
TO PASS TO JUDY. COMMITTEE
KALRA I KALRA HI FLORA. FLORA
HI GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I HATE
JONES SAWYER OKAY JONES SAWYER.
HI YES RAY IS HI ZERO HI ALL
RIGHT LORD. IT'S LORD HI ZERO
HI THE BILLS OUT WE ARE
JURISDICTION- THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AB. I WANT THAT
TESTIMONY WRITTEN AND.